الى كوسوفو اعتقلت الشرطه احد عناصرها
للاشتباه باطلاقه الناره خارج ساعات خدمته
على شابين من الاقليه الصربيه واصابتهما
قرب بلده ستربسا وادانا رئيس وزراء كوسوفو
البينكورتي الهجوم على الشابين مغربا عن
قلقه البالغ على حالتهما في سياق المتصل
زادت الشرطه دورياتها عقب الحادثه كما
قالت قوات حفظ السلام التي يقودها الناتو
في كوسوفي انها عزت اجراءاتها ودورياتها
وانها لا تنوي زياده عدد جنودها ولم تتلقى
اي طلب رسميا بذلك من حكومه برشتنام ياتي
هذا التطور بعد ايام قليله من ازاله حواجز
نصبها شماليه البلاد لاسابيع احتجاجا على
قراراته حكومه كوسوفو
وقدنا الاتحاد الاوروبي بشده اطلاق النار
على طفل وشاب من الاقليه الصربيه عشيه
الميلاد وقال المتحدث باسم المفوض
العلاقات الخارجيه الاوروبيه ان من المهم
ان تحقق السلطات بشكل كامل في هذه الجريمه
التي وصفها بالنقراء وتحقيق العداله
ينضم الينا من بريشتنا مراسلنا محمد
المدهون محمد ما طبيعه الموقف الان بعد
حادثه الامس
نعم سلمى اذا بعد يامن قليله فقط من
الهدوء اثر تفكيك تلك الحواجز يعود الان
خطر تجدد هذه التوترات بهذا الحادث الذي
شهدته بلده جنوبيه البلاد وهي على المقلب
الاخر من البلدات التي شهدت التوترات
سابقه خلال الشهر الماضي في شماليه البلاد
شرطي هو من الالبان اطلق النار خارج ساعه
خدمته على فتن وشاب سربيين واحد عمره 11
عاما والاخر عمره 21 عاما حالتهما مستقره
في المستشفى وتم اعتقال هذا الشرطي وهناك
ادانا شديدا من قبل كل الجهات الحكوميه
رئيس الوزراء الكوسوفي اصدر بيانا شديد
اللهجه دان فيه هذا الحادث وطالب كل
المؤسسات الحكوميه بالتعامل معه بحزم
الحادث بحد ذاته تمتوائه ولكن الخشيه هي
الان من تداعياته خاصه ان
احداث الشهر الماضي احداث شهر ديسمبر
والتقطيع الطرق والحواجز والمتاريس التي
نصبت كانت الشراره التي اشعلتها هي اعتقال
شرطي من الاقليه السرديه بتهمه تخطيطه
لتنفيذ اعتداءات ضد لجان انتخابات المحليه
في الشمال اثر ذلك جاءت كل هذه الاضطرابات
الان الحكومه الكوسوفيه امام اختبارا
حقيقي كيف ستتعامل مع هذا الشرطي الذي
ينتمي الى الاغلبيه الالبانيه هل ستتعامل
معه بالحزم نفسه همم هذا هو السؤال
المطروح وستكون هناك تظاهرات كبيره غدا في
تلك البلده التي شهدت هذا الحادث قد يترتب
على اثرها تكرار مثل تلك المشاهد من اغلاق
للطرق وتقطيع
الشوارع ولكن في هذه الاثناء التاكيد من
الجميع بان هذا الحادث يجب ان يبقى معزولا
وان لا تكون له اي تداعيات مشابهه لما حدث
الشهر الماضي محمد المدهون مراسلنا من
بريشتينها شكرا لك